[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
y ya está conmigo en el estudio del
examen de zúrich el louis es bienvenido
buena mañana de viernes vamos a hablar
de diversos países de américa latina de
nuestra región porque están dando pasos
para llevar a cabo reformas laborales
así que esa es raúl lo primero que se
debe tomar en cuenta es que este ha sido
un tema de debate tanto a nivel
gubernamental como en algunos espacios
del sector privado desde mediados de la
década de 1990 no obstante la llegada de
gobiernos orientados más a lo social y
pensando en mejorar las condiciones de
vida del trabajador se han producido
algunos cambios en las leyes laborales
que de acuerdo con un estudio publicado
por la organización internacional del
trabajo en el año 2005 estaban
justificados en la necesidad de generar
empleo también por la importancia de
eliminar la rigidez existente en la
legislación e instituciones de trabajo
que parecían impedir a las empresas
adecuarse a la actividad económica la
reforma laboral tiene diversos aspectos
a tomar en cuenta y uno de ellos guarda
relación con el tiempo que un individuo
debe dedicar al trabajo en chile por
ejemplo el presidente gabriel boric ha
abierto nuevamente un debate respecto a
reducir la actual cantidad de horas
semanales de 45 a 40 de concretarse
sería la segunda reducción en casi 20
años recordemos que en 2013 las jornadas
semanales en chile pasó de 48 horas a
las actuales 45 respecto a la 40 horas
como se le conoce al proyecto que no es
nuevo pues ya fue una propuesta
realizada en el año 2017 por la entonces
diputada y hoy ministra del gabinete de
boris que camila vallejo el jefe de
estado pidió al parlamento mayor
celeridad en los debates le hemos puesto
una urgencia razonable para que pueda
ser debatido en el parlamento para que
pueda ser perfeccionado en la medida que
los parlamentarios y parlamentarias así
lo estimen pero con la convicción de que
tiene que avanzar
y tiene que avanzar también conscientes
de las vicisitudes de las que nos
enfrentamos pero de acuerdo con algunos
medios y estudios en chile la iniciativa
podría impactar de manera directa a más
de 4 millones de trabajadores y ya el
presidente chileno ha avanzado en
discusiones con sindicatos y también con
el sector empresarial se debe dejar
claro que debe aprobarse esta iniciativa
su efecto no será inmediato sino que
deberá aplicarse en un periodo de cinco
años desde el anuncio el jefe de estado
en la nación se ha iniciado una serie de
debates para evaluar los proyectos
contraste la iniciativa escuchemos parte
de lo que han sido estas intervenciones
el numeral número 3 establece que la
política en salud pública debe
construirse en base a los determinantes
sociales
esto es bien relevante porque
la jornada laboral es un determinante
social que afecta la calidad de vida de
las personas y de las familias en chile
tenemos en la jornada de 45 horas que a
propósito ante era de 48 y cuando
discutimos en aquel año en que se logró
cambiar a 45 se decían las mismas cosas
que hoy día bueno en esa ocasión no pasó
eso sino que diversos estudios indicaron
que no sólo no ocurrió eso sino que
mejoró la productividad louis chile
sería el único país que avanza digamos
en una modificación de este tipo en los
actuales momentos en cuanto a la jornada
laboral sí pero debemos tomar en cuenta
que en julio del año 2021 hace poco más
de un año el presidente entonces de
colombia iván duque firmó una ley que
redujo la jornada laboral en ese país de
48 a 42 horas semanales esto será a
partir de un periodo de cuatro años pero
por otro lado el presidente actual
estado petro también informado sobre una
reforma más amplia legislación actual
esta iniciativa tendría como objetivo
primordial mejorar el clima laboral para
el empleado en colombia para lograrlo
busque una reivindicación de los
derechos laborales como el pago de las
obras extras los extras nocturnas que
estarían a partir de las seis de la
tarde adicionalmente busca la equidad
salarial entre hombres y mujeres y
también busca poner fin a los contratos
de prestación de servicios esto
en el sentido de colocar mayor
estabilidad laboral pero si bien se
esperaba que todo el proceso para lograr
el establecimiento de la ley incluyendo
las conversaciones y la discusión en el
parlamento se realizara este año el
propio jefe de estado colombiano anunció
que se haría para el año 2023 cuando
haría la presentación formal pero que
este periodo es decir desde agosto hasta
el mes de enero sería aprovechado para
conversar con todas las partes
involucradas no obstante luego de un
encuentro con sindicatos representantes
empresariales e integrantes del
ministerio de trabajo colombiano se
acordó la agenda para la presentación de
informes ante la organización del
trabajo
pero también hay ejemplos digamos en
nuestra región de reformas laborales
similares a las que propone colombia
esto en cuanto a la jornada laboral de
40 días a la semana sí y como un ejemplo
de ello podemos citar el caso venezolano
cuya legislación laboral ya cumplió una
década este año aquella ley firmada por
el entonces presidente de hugo chávez
además de tener una jornada laboral de
40 horas semanales presenta
modificaciones significativas
a las mejoras de las prestaciones
sociales el bono vacacional también en
modificaciones en los periodos de
maternidad y paternidad ahora mirando el
futuro le pregunto si hay iniciativas
similares en otros países de américa
latina si hay varios países que están
planteando reformas a su legislación
laboral pero en medio de lo que ha sido
la campaña electoral por la presidencia
de brasil el actual candidato luis
ignacio lula da silva a través del
partido de los trabajadores ha mostrado
interés en derogar la ley del trabajo
promulgada en el año 2017 bajo el mando
del entonces presidente michel temer
esto por una legislación que defienda y
proteja a los trabajadores e instaure
derechos y fortalezca a los sindicatos
construyendo un nuevo sistema de
contratación colectiva que podría
incluir a los trabajadores del sector
informal y también a los que se
desarrollan en aplicaciones louis como
siempre gracias por toda la información
económica más adelante más economía
nosotros seguimos en directo américa